suppose we have a rigid body and it's
rotating about a fixed axis and we know
that the angular acceleration alpha is
given now it may be a function of time
and we'd like to find from this the
angular velocity and how much angle has
rotated in some time interval so the
first thing we have to do is choose a
point in the rigid body and introduce a
coordinate system here we have our angle
theta and with this point we have our R
hat and our theta hat direction and
recall that by the right hand rule the K
hat is going out of the plane of the
figure and so we have our coordinate
system and we wrote alpha as the second
derivative of theta with respect to time
k hat now our goal is to find Omega
which will write as the first derivative
of D theta DT K hat and also to find
theta as a function of time now recall
that our notation was that alpha Z was
the Omega Z DT equals d squared theta DT
squared and in this notation Omega Z was
equal to D theta DT now what we're gonna
do is we're gonna integrate alpha just
like we did in simple circular motion
kinematics for point-like objects and so
what we have here is that for some time
interval Omega Z at time t minus Omega Z
0 is the integral of T prime equals 0 to
T of alpha Z which is our component of
the angular acceleration we have an
integration variable DT Prime and recall
that that implies that Omega ZT can have
some initial value at time T equals 0
Plus this integral relationship which is
what we want to figure out by direct
integration now this only works when
alpha Z
is some function of time in order to get
the angle theta of T we use we integrate
again where we have theta of T zero is
the integral from T prime equals zero to
T prime equals T of this function Omega
Z again we have some integration
variable T prime DT Prime and so we see
that theta of T can have some initial
value plus this integral relationship T
prime equals T of Omega Z T prime DT
Prime and this is how we can figure out
the how the point P has an nth component
of angular velocity and what angle the
quant the point P sweeps out in sum what
time interval T